did you know the two out of every three
guys would experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
look I know for me it was more like 25.
I wish keeps been around when I was
younger because advancements in science
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have you
could get an expert's treatment plan
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or Pharmacy delivered directly to your
front door all at about half the cost of
a traditional Pharmacy yes keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
your hair growth and because it's a
simple subscription model their regular
refill reminders and fast shipping will
keep you stocked on all the product that
you need to take care of your hair how
does it work well for one thing you
don't need to visit a doctor's office
just schedule a quick online consult a
little bit later a discrete package will
arrive at your door and you can use it
in the privacy of your own home each
treatment plan comes with a year of free
messaging so you can connect with your
medical provider at any time the hair
loss stops with keeps you guys can get
50 off your order by going to keeps.com
biographics that's k-e-p-s dot com slash
biographics or just clicking the link in
the description below and again then I
get you 50 off your first order and now
today's video
there's something about buried treasure
that captivates the mind it's plot of
almost every good adventure story The
Hunt for a lost Fortune every kid in
many adults dream of following a
treasure map to find a chest of Gold
Silver and jewels left there by a pirate
or an unlucky Adventurer for one man the
dream of hunting treasure became a
reality Mel Fisher left comfortable life
in California to come to the Florida
Keys in search of sunken treasure he
alongside family and friends spent years
chasing his white whale a Spanish
Galleon that sunk 400 years ago with an
unimaginable amount of wealth on board
the quest to find the treasure would be
dangerous expensive monotonous and
frustrating with Mel having to battle
Mother Nature the limits of
technological innovation the government
of the State of Florida that of course
the many threats that lurk beneath the
ocean's surface this is a story of a man
who chased a dream despite it almost
costing him everything and in the end he
ended up making history
Melvin Lewis Fisher was born on August
21 1922 in Hobart Indiana a residential
Town located not far from the coastline
of Lake Michigan he had a comfortable
childhood his father Earl was a
successful Carpenter and his mother
Grace was a dance instructor Mel grew up
to be tall skinny and always ready for
adventure the especially liked swimming
and boating in the area's many lakes and
rivers he also liked tinkering with
stuff when he was a teenager he built a
homemade diving helmet out of a paint
can he attended Purdue University after
high school studying engineering one of
the most famous breast lecturers during
his time at school was Albert Einstein
who Fisher greatly admired before Mel
could complete his studies World War II
intervened and he ended up in the U.S
Army Corps of Engineers sent to Europe
as part of the support infrastructure
for the Allied infantry assault on the
Nazis he was never in direct combat but
was bombed during the Battle of the
Bulge escaping unhurt mostly he built
stuff like latrines a lot of latrines
after the war Fisher returned to the
United States and went into the booming
post-war construction business he was
fishing on a bridge in Florida one day
when he encountered a man spear fishing
under the water diving down to shoot
these huge fish that Mel had never seen
before he asked the man to show him how
and a lifelong obsession with the world
under the sea was born
[Music]
with World War II over Frenchman Jack
Cousteau began exporting his new
invention the Aqualung the first
commercially available self-contained
underwater breathing apparatus or scuba
Cousteau would go on to use his Aqua
Lung to gain Renown as a famous
underwater Explorer and filmmaker back
in the United States Mel bought one of
the first aqualungs for sale in the
country and he immediately saw the
appeal no longer would a dive as time
under War to be limited to how long he
could hold his breath instead of minutes
you could spend hours down there fisher
was in California at the time making a
go of being a chicken farmer but he
spent as much time as he could diving he
tinkered with breathing Regulators dive
suits and spear guns until he eventually
decided to sell his farm and open a dive
shop in Los Angeles not only did his
shop sell diving equipment it also
offered scuba diving lessons an
organized dive trips to many of the
beautiful underwater beasters off the
California coast he also filmed
television shows for local TV stations
educating the public about the exciting
Adventures that Scuba Diving off it this
in turn provided plenty of traffic to
his business life was good for Mel
Fisher he had met and married the love
of his life Dolores known to everyone as
Dio and together they had four children
Dirk Kane Kim and Taffy Dio loved diving
as much as Mel did and the whole family
got into the business which was both
commercially successful and earned Mel a
lot of friends in the process that would
come in handy later on one of the most
popular destinations for divers was
shipwrecks most ships are sunk in
shallow water easily accessible for
scuba divers Mel was always on the
lookout for shipwrecks while diving he
liked to explore them and sometimes he
was able to salvage something from them
like a ship's propeller or a cannon the
idea of sunken treasure began to
Fascinate him and the more time he spent
diving on Rex the more he began to
believe that he could become a treasure
hunter just like he dreamed about when
he was a boy reading books about pirates
in 1964 melfisher surprised everybody
when he abruptly sold all of his
business interests in California and
packed up and moved the family to
Southern Florida the Fisher family were
making a go of being professional
treasure Hunters
foreign
Mel's new home base was Vero Beach right
in the middle of Florida's Treasure
Coast it's called this because in 1715
an entire fleet of Spanish galleons
carrying treasure back to Europe was
wrecked in a hurricane sending their
valuable cargo to the bottom many
Salvage Expeditions have been undertaken
over the years to recover portions of
the treasure and the Fishers decided to
make another attempt the modern treasure
Hunters approach is much more methodical
and well pretty boring compared to the
exciting Adventures depicted in
fictional Treasures there are no
treasure maps no Puzzles or Clues to
solve and even if you know exactly where
the Shipwreck is that doesn't
necessarily mean that's where the
treasure is since centuries of ocean
currents can drag things far away from
the rest there are a lot of steps
involved but basically the way it works
is that Fisher's ship would tow a
floating magnetic meter behind it
trawling for magnetic anomalies on the
ocean floor a hit would indicate that
some kind of ferrous meta was down there
like iron which could indicate a
shipwreck scuba divers would investigate
the site to see if they could figure out
what it is using a device fish are
invented called a mailbox to force clear
water from the surface down onto the
ocean floor blowing away the sand and
debris the divers would inspect the
ocean floor usually by panning sweeping
their hands back and forth through the
murky sand trawling with their fingers
for objects if the object is buried in
the sand they would have to dig a hole
in order to locate it after all that
time-consuming work the odds were that
whatever they found wasn't what they
were looking for Fisher's team found
wrecks of airplanes and dummy practice
bombs dropped during training by World
War II era pilots and also a lot of
trash scrap metal illegally dumped into
the ocean or it might be a shipwreck but
it's from the wrong era Civil War
vintage or early 1900s instead of an
18th century sailing ship Fisher spent
almost an entire year out at Sea looking
for Treasure and finding nothing of
value at all just when he was about to
quit one of his mailboxes uncovered a
sea bed completely covered in gold coins
unlike other metals when submerged for
extended periods gold doesn't oxidize or
lose its luster the Spanish gold was
just as shiny as it had been in 1715
when it first entered of the water Bell
Fisher was now firmly in the treasure
hunting business
in 1969 after five years of working the
Treasure Coast Mel and his family took a
vacation down to Key West which back in
those days was a small town full of
people who wanted to be Beach buns as
opposed to the tourist destination that
it is today during a party attended with
other professional Hunters Fisher first
heard about the richest prize yet to be
plucked from the sea the Nuestra Senora
de toha way back in 1622 the Atoka was a
Spanish Galleon that left Havana Laden
with a mind-boggling 400 million dollars
worth of gold silver and gemstones there
was so much treasure on board it had
taken two months to probably catalog and
store it on the ship then only two days
after setting sailed disaster the fleet
sailed into a hurricane and the atoha
along with seven other ships were lost
Spanish authorities made efforts to
salvage what they could find from the
wrecked ships but no trace of the atoha
had been found in the 350 years since it
sank the otoho was a treasure Hunter's
dream anyone who could find it would not
only be rich but famous as well Bel
Fisher decided to try and find it
optimistically he thought it would take
six weeks to to find using his modern
methods it's dead it ended up taking 16
years Fisher's company treasure salva's
Inc sold their rights to the Treasure
Coast Fleet wrecks and moved their
operations to Key West looking for the
etoha as well as anything else they
could find in the area once again it was
monotonous time-consuming back-breaking
work with little to nothing to show for
it still Fisher was eternally optimistic
that he was going to succeed his
catchphrase said every day before his
team started work was today's the day
the first breakthrough came in 1971 when
one officer's friend an expert in
document analysis who was studying old
papers in a Spanish archive discovered
that the location the Spanish government
believed the Ottawa sunk was totally
different from where Fisher thought it
was they'd been looking in the wrong
place once they course corrected they
started finding bits and pieces of
treasure silver bars basketballs pieces
of pottery or a cannon Bishop believed
they were from the ship but they hadn't
yet found what he called the big pile
the main body of wreckage where most of
the Lost be throughout the 1970s and
into the 1980s they continued to search
investing millions of dollars into the
search wreck diving is a dangerous
business there are all sorts of risks
inherent to scuba diving like the
failure of your scuba gear which could
cause you to drown surfacing do quickly
to avoid drowning but you're at risk of
decompression sickness a dangerous
buildup of nitrogen bubbles in the
bloodstream that dive is called the bend
there are also countless sea creatures
down there that could harm you sharks
Barracuda stingrays jellyfish Portuguese
man of war but the biggest threat to the
operation came from the ever-changing
whims of Mother Nature more than once
their boat was struck by lightning
shorting out all of their electrical
systems the worst danger came from
tropical storms like the hurricane that
sank theatoha in the first place after
skirting the hazards for years it
finally caught up to the Fisher family
in 1975. one of their boats capsized and
sank while the crew on board slept three
people including Mel's 21 year old son
Dirk a Dirk's wife Angel drowned
foreign
Mel Fisher had lived in Key West for 16
years in that time he had become one of
the town's most celebrated citizens he
had lots of friends and his treasure
hunting Museum was one of the Island's
top tourist spots he had been looking
for the big pile of the atoha ever since
it got in there and though it found and
salvaged other Treasures including 20
million dollars worth of gold from
atoha's sister ship the Santa Margarita
he hadn't yet struck the motherload then
on July the 20th his son Kane told Mel
over the radio put the charts away Dad
we found it Mel rushed out to the scene
and beheld the astonishing side of his
team stacking hundreds of 75 pound
silver bars on the deck of their boat so
many that they started to worry about
the weight of it sinking the ship 55
feet down on the seabed there was more
gold bars jewelry coins stacks of silver
Pieces Of Eight that had become fused
together while the wooden chest had been
stored in had rotted away clusters of
emeralds and Pearls it just kept going
they even found a solid gold Implement
shaped like a syringe that was used to
administer gunpowder and char alcohol
enemas a popular 17th century Health
cure it was the culmination of an entire
life's work a treasure valued between
four and five hundred million dollars
one can only imagine how he felt many
people ventured out to the wreck site to
congratulate him among them with
celebrated musician and Key West native
Jimmy Buffett who brought his guitar and
sang a couple of songs while the crew
celebrated a week later Mel was invited
to appear on Johnny Carson's late night
show the veteran host was fascinated by
the treasure Fisher brought with him and
a week later he invited Carson out to
the Rec site to dive down and get some
treasure for himself bell used the
platform provided by Carson's show to
talk about an issue had been dealing
with for over a decade that's what he
called piracy ever since traces of the
otoha had been found in 1972 the Florida
state government had attempted to claim
the treasure saying that according to
Florida law any and all shipwrecks
located within Florida waters are the
property of the government they forced
treasure salvas into a contract that
gave the government 25 of the treasure
threatening Fisher with arrest and
confiscation if he didn't agree 3. two
years later after oil companies filed a
lawsuit the Supreme Court fixed the
coastal boundary of Florida further
landward than before which placed the
wreck in international waters so the
Fishers filed a lawsuit of their own
claiming the treasure seizure had been
illegal since it was never Florida to
begin with after a langsly court case
that ended up before the U.S Supreme
Court in 1982 the judges ruled in Mel's
paper the otoha was his and all the Seas
treasure needed to be returned to him
even so Fisher claimed that he faced
continued harassment and red tape by
Florida officials complaining about
government interference in what he
believed was a free and private
Enterprise answering concerns about the
historical value of the shipwrecks
Fisher argued that his company was doing
a better job of preserving the artifacts
in question then the government was
leaving them down in the ocean to rot it
would not be the last time the question
of government versus business would be
asked in regards to treasure hunting
the last decade of his life was a good
one for Mel Fisher he had succeeded
Beyond anyone's expectations becoming
one of the world's most famous treasure
Hunters contrary to popular belief
however he didn't keep the entire vast
Fortune raged from the wreck of the
atoha and retired to the Caribbean with
it a lot of treasure was distributed to
his investors Friends of the Fishers who
had given him money to fund his treasure
Hunting Expeditions of time when it
seemed like he had very little chance of
finding anything several new
millionaires were minted that way more
treasure ended up in public museums and
at universities including his own
treasure Museum on Key West here he
would also sell coins and jewels to
tourists sending middle class
suburbanites home with bits of treasure
as souvenirs his treasure Hunting
Expeditions continued branching out of
the keys to sites all over the world
since treasure salvas was now seen as oh
what if the premier Maritime salvage
companies in the industry he continued
to have run-ins with government
officials though his company was fined
more than half a million dollars in 1997
for destroying parts of the Key West
National Maritime Sanctuary while
looking for Sunken Treasure five years
earlier and Florida cops in indicted one
of his business associates selling
counterfeit coins though Fisher himself
wasn't implicated in any wrongdoing he
remained immensely popular in Key West
though given his troubles with the
government it seemed fitting that he was
four times elected King of The Conch
Republic a tongue-in-cheek effort by
locals to secede from the United States
and form their own Nation Florida's
ceremonial title came with a crown and
scepto which he proudly added to his
treasure horde on December 19 1998
melfish had died at the age of 76
following a long battle with cancer his
remains were cremated and Scattered at
Sea primarily over the site of the atoha
wreck but a small portion was encased in
resin and left at the site of the most
famous shipwreck of all time the Titanic
during a subsequent Expedition there by
one of his friends
today the Fisher family continues to
hunt for sunken treasure at the otoha
site and at other wrecks around the
world as well as operating two stores to
sell treasure to the public on Key West
on Florida Mainland treasure hunting as
an occupation has only gotten more
controversial over the last 25 years
with many arguing it is tantamount to
the tomb robbing committed by European
treasure seekers in Egypt and other
places through the 19th century a
particular concern are operations
conducted by large American or european
companies in third world countries where
the treasure Hunters exploit local
regulations to effectively profit off of
the cultural Treasures of native peoples
one famous recent case involved the
salvage company Odyssey Marine
exploration who in 2007 brought up
almost 15 Tons of gold and silver coins
and other Treasures from the wreck of a
Spanish frigate destroyed off the coast
of Portugal in 1804 despite attempting
to keep it a secret the Spanish
government found out and began legal
action against what it called illegal
looting after a protracted Corps battle
Odyssey Marine was ordered to return the
treasure to the Spanish government in
2012 and it has since gone on display in
a museum UNESCO has started to account
pain to preserve underwater wreckageable
sorts as having cultural and historic
value most treasure Hunting Expeditions
are now forced by law to employ Marine
archaeologists who help to investigate
the wrecks and make judgments on whether
it is possible to safely remove
artifacts from the shipwrecks without
damaging the remainder or whether it
might be better to leave the wreckage
undisturbed it is part of a wider debate
about Antiquities from all over the
world who they belong to and whether
they should be treated as Commodities
able to be bought and sold by private
individuals this likely would have
angered Mel Fisher who lived by The
Motto Finders Keepers after all he and
his team put in the effort of finding
the attire in the first place spent the
money and the time to search bars of
ocean floor risking their lives in some
instances so why shouldn't they get to
keep it but as usual when a pile of gold
is involved there are no easy answers
for Mel Fisher though it never was about
the monetary value of The Treasure of
the atoha just like Captain ahab's hunt
for the white whale wasn't about the
amount of whale oil he could sell from
its carcass it was about the adventure
of the search the quest Quest that
consumed the better part of two decades
and cost the life of his eldest son
atoha was a dream and Mel Fisher
relentlessly chased that dream eternally
optimistic that today was the day until
one day today was the day
we should all be so lucky